do you think there's meaning to it all
uh this life except the urgency that
death provides
and us anxious beings create cool stuff
along the way
is there a deeper meaning and if it is
what is it
well meaning your life actually there
are three meanings of life
great that's great one too sick
two too sick and three to seek
to seek what you know or is there no
answer there
is no answer to that i really think that
the journey is more
important than uh the destination
whatever to be
and i think uh that is uh a journey
and uh is uh in my opinion at the end of
the day
i must admit meaningful in itself and
we must admit that maybe whatever your
destination
might be i'd hang it you know
we may never get there but uh hell was a
great ride
well i don't think there's a better way
to end it silvio thank you for joining
thank you for wasting your extremely
valuable time with me today
joining on this journey uh of seeking
uh something together we found nothing
but it was
it was very fun i really enjoyed it
thank you so much for that
thank you alex rosamina really special
for me to be
interviewed by you
you